All that stuff that I'm sure that'll
equal if not surpass whenever you got it.
Okay. It looks like
it's recording. Okay. So
that's fine.
You got to do
what's great about it is
the most important position.
So we get great feedback from it.
So,
so we're skipping through the,
you know,
a lot more like work on with major
league guys is the timing of his swing.
That's an important thing for them
because really the main thing for it,
for a picture it is, is to throw off
their time. But at the same time,
once they do swing, guys have, you know,
guys are missing out on a tremendous
amount of opportunity even through the
swing. So basically my job is
to park. I look at, you know,
there's the stride,
which is basically a whole nother level.
So with you, we're just going to
work mainly on the ones you swing.
So what I'd like to see you do is I want
you to first feel most of your weight
on your heels.
And when I say that,
I would say about 60 40 and the reason
why I said it's because there is no,
no need for our cats and baseball.
So the only thing that calves will do
is get your center of gravity or ask one
of the fuel that right. Whether
it be through your, okay.
Cause we're going to use that
for the week. When we straighten,
we're going to straighten
it and push that up. Okay.
So I'd like you to feel
that's the one thing,
and I'm not going to put too much in
your head, but that's the one thing.
We'll take some swings,
feeling the weight in that proper place.
And the only other thing I want you
to feel for now, and you do this well,
you get an a slop,
but get into the slot Lao,
your arms and drop and your
spine angle from this angle,
keeping it straight so they're
actually cannot throw three things.
And you can think about just one
would be just one quick question.
What's the weight distribution
by back?
Yeah.
You are 50 50 or a little
bit more on your back leg.
Okay. Whatever's really,
whatever's comfortable,
but you're going to take a step over.
You aren't going to ship.
So it's more, what I've been
trying to do is line up like that,
less of that stuff actually
start like this. So the
star rating is not, okay.
So let's just go with the stripe
and that's right there. Perfect.
So what I'd like to see you do is keep
your bags exactly right there and close
the Shul. Okay? Okay. Now,
once Tim starts to open up the swing,
that's when this arm drops.
So from here,
just like you could think about a pitcher,
pitcher goes like this,
boom is here.
Now the needle himself.
So say the same thing. They
basically been noon, I'll read it.
So basically your same swing
because you're swinging.
I mean really it was,
there's not much to mess with as far
as anything. But what I'm saying.
Okay,
so,
so you're just gonna stand here or what
I want you to do is the weight is the
weight distribution as it is
on your heels and your foot.
I want you to feel as you step
towards the bag and just like I said,
doing natural step,
you don't have to think about it
because you do a very big step. Okay?
So you do a natural step.
The only thing on what you think about is,
yeah,
I want you to,
as the foot lands feel coiled and we're
not going to do any pausing with the leg
or anything like that. I just want
you to do a coiled all right here.
We you're going to explode into get a
down for, um, it's,
it's a preference thing choking up
would be about here and no choke up.
And being about here,
I used to when I played like just
to hold it with a little joke. Okay.
But there are guys it like,
and I'm not really sure why,
but um, if you want to, let's
talk about Greg, just recite
to me,
you know,
this is the one contact you
have with your weapon and um,
the mass is being transformed.
We call about that.
So you want to have what
I call a consistent grip.
And that's not just from the beginning.
That's not just at the end,
but that's through the swing shift.
And I say that because
hitters,
lucid hitters just lose consciousness
through the swing that are focused on the
ball. Unfortunately, they don't
do the training that I do.
So there were, their hands
will come off, you know,
especially if they do
the hands personally.
Hands just simply cannot be the on back.
That was too vast logo or so what I tell
kids and sometimes that's completely
changed their swing is keep the hand
every part of the is on the bed,
keep it on throughout the whole swing.
And that's a seminar that would,
that grabs the entire hand.
So then you know,
it forces you kind of hear
so,
so go ahead.
And I would say just don't worry about
that. Right. Okay.
Okay.
So the one that you're
focused on is actually for
now just get used to it in the
back. Don't even think
about that. Good. Yeah.
Good.
Okay.
Yeah.
So
the reason why it's going the small over,
I was going to be a little
more speed. Okay. Okay. So, uh,
so,
uh,
I want you to feel as your foot lands,
and this is just going to be a momentary
feeling. Feel the shoulders developable.
Yep.
So you're one is going to land
facing down the first baseline. Yep.
Well,
your shoulders are going to be portable
and then as you slow from the ground up,
you're going to unwind that.
Okay.
Good.
And her shoulders.
So it's going to be, it's going to look
like that. It's really just thinking about
your fully wound up
only as your shoulders start to open
new field. So it's like this. Boom.
Okay. So yeah, that's the only thing.
What
I'll do is help in baby steps here to say,
okay,
let's just do this in a second
shoulder. Let's just do that. Yeah.
Don't worry about
anything else. Fall. Work
a little bit
about what you just did
right there. Perfect. Okay,
good.
Do it three more times.
You jumped the gun and
okay. There was one more
time and stay there. Okay.
So I'm just going to go boom.
That's it. That's enough.